don't you love it when the most famous
atheist in the world accidentally agrees
with you and thoroughly undermines his
own
ideology Richard Dawkins spent a lot of
his career offering terrible responses
to Arguments for the existence of God
blasting away at the only Creed that
could keep the United Kingdom at least
Loosely United and Paving the way for
Islam to subjugate the leftover
fragments of his crumbling Society but
more recently Dawkins has been atoning
for his civilization ending blunders by
giving us a bottomless supply of
Christian apologetics gold in his latest
interview with Pierce Morgan Dawkins
provided the building blocks for my
favorite argument against atheism
Dawkins deconstruction of atheism
started when he insisted that his host
Pierce Morgan shouldn't ask what
happened before the Big Bang because the
word before in that context is
meaningless since time itself came into
being at the Big Bang How can there be
before and after when time didn't
exist I'm trying to tell you what a
physicist would say first of all they
would say that you cannot use the word
before for the Big Bang time began at
the Big Bang there was no before before
the Big Bang I know it's contrary to
Common Sense physicists don't
necessarily deal with common sense
notice Dawkins admitted that what he was
saying was contrary contrary to common
sense I know it's contrary to Common
Sense physicists don't necessarily deal
with common sense and Dawkins insists
that non-physicists shouldn't challenge
physicists when physicists say things
that fly in the face of Common Sense we
are not physicists I I like you am
completely baffled by what physicists
say to me which is that you cannot use
the word before for for before the Big
Bang he goes on to acknowledge that what
physicists say about this is
counterintuitive to non-physicists
time itself began in at the at the Big
Bang now that is totally
counterintuitive it's counterintuitive
to me it's counterintuitive to you it's
counterintuitive to Steven Meyer but we
are not physicists then Pierce Morgan
challenges him by saying look I can sit
here and challenge what you claim as a
bio ologist why can't we challenge
physicists when they say something that
sounds really really strange and this is
where things get awesome you cannot use
human intuition human intuition was
built up by by by Evolution over many
millions of years to survive on the
African plane hunting and Gathering
looking for water holes looking for
mates and so on we were our brains were
not built to understand the profundities
of the origin of the universe the the
end of the universe the kind of things
that physicists deal with did you catch
that Dawkins describes the origin of our
cognitive faculties a fancy term for the
mental processes we use to form our
beliefs he mentions human intuition but
what he says applies to all of our
cognitive faculties reason perception
memory and so on what produced our
cognitive faculties how did we get them
human intuition was built up by by by
Evolution over many millions of years to
survive on the African plane hunting and
Gathering looking for water hols looking
for mates and so on our cognitive
faculties were made for helping us
survive they help us find food they help
us find a mate things like that what
were they not made for our brains were
not built to understand the profundities
of the origin of the universe the end of
the universe the kind of things that
physicists deal with our brains weren't
made for physics our brains were so not
made for physics that Dawkins finds it
amazing that any of us can understand
physics I think it's actually amazing
that at least some human brains are
capable of dealing with this kind of
stuff my brain isn't and nor is yours
and now we have everything we need for
some version of What's called the
argument from reason or The evolutionary
argument against naturalism naturalism
is roughly the claim that the natural
world is what exists or what is real
it's what most people used to mean when
they talked about Atheism in the strong
sense because most atheists didn't just
reject God they rejected anything
Supernatural to keep things clear I'll
stick with saying naturalism which is
the position Dawkins is defending
naturalism as opposed to
supernaturalism Dawkins accidentally
showed that naturalism the claim that
the natural world is all that exists is
self-undermining it undermines itself if
you take naturalism seriously you can't
take it seriously why because if you
believe in naturalism you can't trust
the reasoning process that produces your
belief in
naturalism naturalism is a hypothesis
about all of reality if naturalism were
true and you received your cognitive
faculty reason perception memory and so
on from the naturalistic processes that
are available in your world viw then you
can't trust your cognitive faculties
when you're dealing with a topic like
naturalism human reason wasn't made for
anything close to that as doin said our
brains weren't made to understand these
profundities our brains were not built
to understand the profundities of the
origin of the universe the end of the
universe the kind of things that
physicists deal with this is Richard
Dawkins not me Richard Dawkins saying we
can't trust human intuition on topics
like these because human intuition
wasn't made for topics like these this
problem can be a bit difficult to get
your mind around but once you see it you
can't unsee it so let's unpack the
brilliant reputation of naturalism
Richard Dawkins just gave us human
beings have the ability to reason we're
using it right now and we tend to trust
our reasoning ability Pierce Morgan and
Richard Dawkins wouldn't have
discussions about the origin of the
universe or the origin of life and we
wouldn't have these discussions if we
thought that our cognitive faculties the
processes that produce our beliefs were
unreliable but naturalists face two
massive problems here because they can
only explain things by appealing to
Natural objects natural events natural
causes do brought up one of the problems
I'll start with the problem he didn't
bring up think about this for a moment
you have
beliefs ultimately according to
naturalism your beliefs must be the
result of physical processes in your
brain now what's going on in here
particles in motion chemical reactions
neurons firing it's all physical
governed by laws of nature
so what really seems like careful
reasoning to you is in reality
straightforward mechanical mindless
cause and effect it's a fancy array of
falling
dominoes whatever you believe right now
you are determined by Mindless particles
obeying mindless laws of nature to
believe it if your beliefs change over
time your beliefs were determined by
Mindless particles in
to change Illusions aside then you
arrive at your beliefs via a process
that has absolutely nothing to do with
whether those beliefs are true or false
chemicals couldn't conceivably care less
if naturalism is true and you believe in
naturalism right now you were causally
determined by nonrational particles
obeying nonrational laws of nature via a
process set in motion long before you
were born to believe in naturalism if
naturalism is true and you believe in
supernaturalism right now you were
causally determined by nonrational
particles mindlessly obeying
non-rational laws of nature via a
process set in motion long before you
were born to believe in
supernaturalism the particles and the
laws of nature that causally determined
what you believe right now don't care at
all whether your beliefs are true or
false a false belief is every bit as
determined by nonrational particle
interactions as a true belief so if
naturalism is true what sense does it
make to trust our reasoning ability or
our beliefs or even our belief in
naturalism none
whatsoever how can we trust our beliefs
when our beliefs are determined by
nonrational particle interactions we
can't well we can but we shouldn't if
naturalism is true but it gets worse for
atheists because as Dawkins pointed out
your brain wasn't made to get to the
truth about the origin of the universe
or about Ultimate Reality interestingly
Darwin himself eventually saw this
problem let's read what he said Darwin
is responding to William Graham whose
book is the defense of design in nature
Darwin writes to Graham you have
expressed my inward conviction though
far more vividly and clearly than I
could have done that the universe is not
the result of chance but then with me
the horrid doubt always arises whether
the convictions of man's mind which has
been developed from the mind of the
lower animals are of any value or at all
trustworthy would anyone trust in the
convictions of a monkey's mind if there
are any convictions in such a mind
Darwin says that he shares Graham's
conviction that the universe is not the
result of chance but he goes on to say
that he can't trust his convictions
because his mind has been developed from
the mind of the lower
animals one could argue that reliable
cognitive faculties would help organisms
survive and reproduce and would
therefore be selected in the struggle
for survival but this response would be
unsuccessful for several reasons first
even false beliefs can help organisms
survive and reproduce if you refuse to
eat certain deadly berries because you
believe they're poisonous and I refuse
to eat them because I believe they've
been cursed by an angry wizard we both
avoid the berries and we both
survive a false belief can often help
you survive just as well as a true
belief second for purposes of ction
false beliefs can sometimes be more
effective than true beliefs if you've
got the hots for someone but she's
definitely out of your league and you're
too shy to make a move but you call up
the astrology hotline and the psychic
tells you that the position of the
planet Venus is just right for love your
false belief in astrology might give you
the confidence you need to walk up to
her and say what's your name girl what's
your sign she might be so so impressed
by your confidence and she might so love
astrology that you guys have 10 kids
together your false belief can help you
reproduce that's a selection
Advantage third the kinds of beliefs
that help us survive and reproduce are
usually grounded in simple observation
and experience my Cav mate died
eating those berries so I won't eat them
but even the low mammals are capable of
learning by observation and experience
this is how mice learn to avoid
traps human beings obviously have more
developed abilities but not enough to
push their reliability far beyond the
tasks they were selected to perform at
best then we might trust our faculties
in matters that involve finding food or
using a spear against an enemy or doing
something to attract a mate the kinds of
things we were made four you cannot use
human intuition human intuition was
built up by by by Evolution over many
millions of years to survive on the
African plane hunting and Gathering
looking for water hols looking for mates
and so on we were our brains were not
built to understand the profundities of
the origin of the universe the end of
the universe the kind of things that
physicists deal with so naturalism
combined with natural selection gives us
almost no basis for trusting our
reasoning ability when it comes to
theology epistemology ethics physics or
metaphysics as the neurop philosopher
Patricia churchin points out given a
naturalistic interpretation of
evolutionary theory truth takes the
hindmost in the struggle for survival
Churchland writes looked at from an
evolutionary point of view the principal
function of nervous systems is to enable
the organism to move appropriately boy
down to Essentials a nervous system
enables the organism to succeed in the
four FS feeding fleeing fighting and
reproducing the principal chore of
nervous systems is to get the body parts
where they should be in order that the
organism May survive in so far as
representations serve that function
representations are a good thing getting
things right in space and time therefore
is a crucially important factor for
nervous system systems and there is
often considerable evolutionary pressure
deriving from considerations of speed
improvements in sensory motor control
confer an evolutionary Advantage a
fancier style of representing is
advantageous so long as it is geared to
the organism's way of life and enhances
the organism's chances of survival truth
whatever that is definitely takes the
hindmost
if human reasoning ability was selected
simply because it helped members of our
species get the body parts where they
should be as Dawkins believes how can we
have any confidence in the central claim
of
naturalism your mind wasn't made to get
to the truth about all of reality your
mutant Berry finding ability wasn't made
for anything close to here's the correct
theory about everything that exists as
David Hume would say we must be far
removed from the smallest tendency to
skepticism not to be apprehensive that
we have here got quite beyond the reach
of our
faculties so does it make any sense
whatsoever to believe in naturalism when
belief in naturalism undermines the
reliability of the very cognitive
faculties required to affirm a grand
hypothesis like
naturalism not a bit and yet people like
Richard Dawkins do do trust their
cognitive faculties it's as if on some
level they believe their cognitive
faculties are more than just a mutant
Berry finding ability it's as if on some
level they understand that they were
made for more than just survival and
reproduction it's as if on some level
they know they were made for something
great it's as if on some level they know
know they're created in the image of God
and they have to suppress that
knowledge exactly as the Bible says
[Music]